my daughter thinks I'm a mechanic I
actually had to to take her on set with
me she goes Daddy what are you doing I'm
like I just I'm just fixing the car and
we're out the door Paul Walker's
daughter meadow walker is
with a cameo in the latest chapter of
The Fast and Furious franchise
hey I thought you could leave without
saying goodbye
the 24 year old model whose dad starred
in the action franchise for nearly a
decade until his 2013 death is set to
appear in the latest installment fast
10. I knew you would come for me how
about we all just start shooting each
other
let's dig some Graves there is no one
involved in fast one that could even
fathom no concept of 20 some years later
any version of this movie would still be
around and if we get another two months
out of it how lucky are we I'm just very
grateful
to play my little part Meadow shared the
news on Instagram Thursday posting this
pic in character
Paul's daughter was one year old when
the OG flick was released your daughter
must think you're like the coolest dad
in the whole wide world she thinks I'm a
dork
Meadow says she grew up on set watching
her dad Vin Diesel Jordana Brewster
Michelle Rodriguez Ludacris and others
on the monitors my biggest concern as a
parent it's like you want to be
protective and so what I would tendency
to do is just I bubble up too much right
and I can see you're going no no she
really wants to see it so there's been
kind of a perspective switch with me
which is more now you know what she
wants to see it she's going to see it
and she may as well see it with me
thanks to my dad I was born into the
fast family
I can't believe
see me grow up he was the most humble
individual on Earth you know he he just
continues to expire inspire me to do
more even me thinking about what he
accomplished and the things that he did
while he was here on this Earth his
daughter Meadow I mean lives on through
him and she is absolutely amazing human
being I am so blessed to be able to
honor my father's Legacy and share this
with him forever you know the Legacy
lives on I mean it's it's out of this
world Meadow was 15 years old when her
dad died in a car crash at 40. there's
not a day that we've filmed
it's not a moment of thought and
creation that his Spirit isn't with us I
can't
think about a fast and furious without
him being a part of it in one way or
another
since then she's remained close with the
fast family there's only one Paul Walker
in fact Vin who is Meadow's Godfather
walked her down the aisle at her 2021
wedding to Louis Thornton Allen and
while we'll just have to wait to learn
more about Meadow's character in fast 10
we do know Jason Momoa joins the cast
I'm gonna go do fast 10. that's gonna be
fun yeah then Jordana Ludacris Michelle
Tyrese Gibson John Cena Jason Statham
Rita Moreno Helen Mirren Brie Larson
cardi B Charlize Theron add more will
also appear in the flick I get to work
with Charlize she's amazing aside from
Charlize who are you most looking
forward to working with I think that'll
be fun we're gonna get like a you and
Vin Throwdown action scene maybe I'm
sure that's probably why they hired me
the devil's coming
[Music]
and we'll be sure to buckle up for
Meadows Cameo when fastx pulls into
theaters on May 19th
[Music]